what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to comics explained a
youtube channel where i will make you a
comic book expert in 30 minutes or less
and in this video we are covering lady
loki or
the time loki became a chick now here's
the thing uh this is a pretty
short run in loki's history when i say
short i mean only for a couple years and
a lot of it came out of the events of
house of m
as well as thor ragnarok so the way this
is basically played out
is that in the aftermath of our last
video where we essentially talked about
thor dying and the idea that thor
had just kind of been removed from the
landscape along with the other
asgardians
j michael cerzinski took over as the
writer of thor
and man i gotta say thor's hair look at
thor's hair on that comic man there's
some
beautiful luscious locks going on there
did you guys know
that two out of three men will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35
and so the best way to prevent hair loss
is to do something about it while you
still have hair left
this video is sponsored by keeps what is
keeps
keeps is a subscription service that
focuses on making it easier and more
affordable
for men to treat their male pattern
baldness online
with keeps a licensed doctor will review
your information online and recommend
the right hair loss treatment for you
then your treatment ships directly to
your door every three months
now prevention is key here and keeps
treatment typically takes between four
to six months to start seeing results so
i support and act fast
the sooner you start using keeps the
more of those luscious locks you can
save
so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
comics explain or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash comics explained but back
to our video j michael cerzinski and
really even marvel in a
as a larger entity had looked at loki
and come to the realization that loki's
old stories really were pretty bland
where they really weren't that
interesting or that great and so the
desire was to make the character more
complex and a lot more interesting but
to also make his plans more nuanced in
a lot of ways more in depth and and with
a little more complication to them and
so what you saw here was kind of this
long-running plan that began with the
return of loki as a woman and then ran
all the way up to the events
of what was basically thor number 600
and the return of boer the father of
odin right so the way this played out is
you essentially had
thor kind of returning back to life and
then coming to the realization that he
was the only asgardian to basically come
back now he had kind of met with his
alter ego donald blake and donald
blake's response was kind of like hey
like it's your job to find everyone and
laura come to this realization that the
asgardians their essences their spirits
were still alive but they had been
inhabited or placed inside the bodies of
other people which was really a way for
marvel to kind of reference the old
donald blake concept right and so what
ended up happening here
really i would say in the first six
issues uh is that you basically had thor
traveling around from location to
location and basically
waking up the various asgardians who
existed out there now the first person
to wake up was heimdall just because of
the fact that he needed the eyes of
heimdall to be able to know who you know
where the various people were otherwise
he'd have to literally travel
based on hearsay and conjecture right
like a person did some crazy thing in
this town
okay that might be the warriors three
right instead of having to do that he
actually had heimdall to essentially
point him in the direction of the
various people who were there now in
issue number five
of strazinski's run he ended up
traveling to what was basically a kind
of prison of sorts where
various humans had kind of been gathered
together and then held as prisoners by
the destroyer armor now when thor got
there what you ended up having was him
trying to really wake up sith
only to find out that loki had inhabited
the body that was meant for seth and
that's why loki appears as a woman but
following that it was an interesting
concept because loki immediately went to
baldur the brave who's kind of this
member of the asgardian royal family and
really kind of throws out this idea that
he's kind of seen the error of his ways
right he's basically a good guy now that
he's kind of been born a new and then
his physical form is a reflection of
that now again this was kind of the
beginning of this sort of long-running
campaign and pretty much everybody
bought it right it was one of those
things because of the standing that
balder has among the asgardians if
balder believes in a person the other
asgardians will as well
and a lot of people actually believe
more in baldr than they do in thor
they follow thor because he's the king
of asgard and he protects them but if
they have to make the choice of who they
believe is the most honest or the most
honorable a lot of them would choose
baldur right because he is in a lot of
ways so incredibly pure when it comes to
his character in the marvel mythos um
you did see a couple schemes here and
there but one of the most notable came
during the dark rain event now the dark
rain event
was really a product that came in the
aftermath of
the events of secret invasion right now
most of you guys know about secret
invasion or
if you have kind of a passing glance of
it all that it really happened here is
it came out of the illuminati storyline
right where you had like charles xavier
you had reed richards you had a handful
of people who were kind of operating
behind the scenes and monitoring the
various threats on earth and it
essentially traveled to the scroll home
world following the creed scroll of war
and because of how close it came to
earth and they essentially issued an
ultimatum to the to the scroll empire
never to come back to earth again what
did what it did is it led to the scrolls
essentially knocking out the various
members of the illuminati and then
copying their dna and then just kind of
using it for some future campaign that
may or may never come to fruition what
ended up happening following that is you
saw galactus destroy the world of the
scrolls and so the squirrels hunting for
a new home world began to secretly
invade the planet earth and when they
did that they started copying the
various superheroes who existed out
there and then replacing them with
scroll duplicates and that's the
entirety of the secret invasion
storyline more or less what was going on
now at the end of the secret invasion
storyline
norman osborne who was essentially just
kind of a
you know ran his own company and we know
him as a green goblin largely a villain
intercepted
information that would end the war and
he successfully did it following that
the u.s government looked at tony stark
who had been the director of shield
following the events of civil war and
found themselves asking the question how
did you not see this coming and so
because they saw it as just a
incredible display of ineptitude they
ultimately kicked him out as director of
shield and replaced him with norman
osborn following that norman osborne
immediately disbanded shield and then
reformed it as an extension of his
company hammer
and then in turn started bringing in
villains and so that's one of the things
that you saw
lady loki do was actually become part of
norman oswar's cabal now following that
and thor issue number 600 where we had
talked about the the last video that we
did where loki had gone into the past to
essentially solidify his own existence
by basically destroying bohr's physical
body and leaving his essence stuck in
the snow
that loki traveled to that exact
location and brought boar back but when
he did
boar had come to this realization that
odin was not the one who returned him
and believing the only way in which that
would happen is if odin died began to go
on a war path this was exacerbated by
the fact that loki had cast a spell that
had driven boar to see everybody as an
enemy and so over the course of issue
number 600 you literally see
boar the father of odin just going on
this war path and attacking everything
in sight
ultimately thor catches up to boar and
then because of boar's rampage and the
strength he possesses
not realizing that he's actually the
father of odin ends up destroying boar
and so the result of this is that when
lady loki goes to baldur she kind of
asks the question in sort of a hint hint
nudge nudge kind of fashion
if thor killed the former king of asgard
even if he's not the king
anymore then didn't he technically kill
a member of the royal family and that's
punishable by death and banishment and
the response of baldr was
yes and so ultimately thor's vanished
from asgard now following that and as
part of norman osborne's cabal
uh lady loki actually ended up bringing
asgard directly to doctor doom or at
least intending to bring the asgardians
directly to doctor doom in the kingdom
of latviria but with thor
and and really as alternate persona
donald blake still being banished
loki intended to return back to the
normal form that loki was supposed to
operate just because of the fact that
this was kind of the conclusion of the
first phase of loki's plan and so one of
the things that goes on here
is that you kind of go into the mighty
avengers as it was written at the time
by dan slott now dan slots mighty
avengers and even really just the mighty
avengers themselves
were largely predicated on the events of
civil war right so the way that works
and it was a genius move by marvel to
launch it because the avengers were
already so popular at the time but the
way this worked is that you essentially
had the traditional avengers team and
the avengers team in a lot of ways had
been disbanded leading up to the events
of
civil war but then of course you had
like the new avengers that had kind of
been reformed in the aftermath of the
elimination of the original avengers
team but
the issue you had is that once civil war
kicked out uh the entire superhuman
community was just split down the middle
and so the new avengers were by all
standards of measurement
defunct and so what remained of the new
avengers were basically those who were
loyal to tony stark with captain america
having his own secret avengers and those
who stood against tony stark and so
with the very really with tony stark and
hank pym and reed richards ultimately
coming out on top in the sense that
superhuman registration basically won
out when captain america
has essentially surrendered at the end
of the civil war conflict uh that you
ended up having the creation of the
mighty avengers who were was basically a
carol danvers led superhero team that
traveled around
and tracked those individuals and
snatched them up if they had not
adequately registered what dan slott did
here is he essentially had lady loki
take on the form of of the scarlet witch
who had basically been missing in the
aftermath of the events of house of m
and then create our own avengers team
and this was really done for the purpose
of trying to find a way to defeat
cathone who would essentially awoken in
wondergore mountain now the idea was
that cathone took the body of
quicksilver in an effort to kind of race
around the world as fast as he could and
influence the world as fast as possible
with loki pretending to be the scarlet
witch launching her own campaign to kind
of stand against the throne so i
wouldn't go as far as to say
this was loki being a hero but i will go
as far as to say it was loki doing at
least something good
right something decent now ultimately
this all came to a head uh when you
ended up having
cassie lange who was the daughter of
scott lang and who at the time was
technically part of the young avengers
and the team in the aftermath of the
children's crusade storyline ended up
summoning
scarlet witch directly to them and when
they did the disguise of loki was
basically removed right and so loki was
ultimately defeated and that was
basically it
what you ended up getting was kind of
lucky going back into his normal male
form and then returning back as the
cabal or part of the cabal of norman
osborn and that's when you go into the
events of
siege on asgard now see john asgard was
a storyline that basically saw
thor kind of abandoning this notion that
he had been banished from asgard when
you ended up having
norman osborn and his forces the dark
avengers and even some of the dark x-men
launching an attack against asgard
itself and the reason behind this was
that asgard was one of the last holdouts
right that when you had uh the dark
green event happening and you had things
like the x-men
leaving westchester and moving to utopia
which was an island off the coast of san
francisco then technically they were not
part of the united states so there
wasn't really anything that norman
osborne could do with them
but uh in the aftermath of ragnarok and
during j michael cerzinski's run
that asgard had been restored in
brockton oklahoma and just hovering
about a foot off the ground or something
like that
and so because of the fact that it
occupied space in the united states
itself
it was really the only thing that norman
osborne needed to launch an attack
against it
under the idea that they were standing
against registration and against the
desire of shield to kind of continue its
charter or at least shield as it existed
under norman osborn and so what you saw
was the century who had essentially
given
in to the power of the void his evil
persona along with a handful of other
dark avengers all attacking asgard
because of the power that the century
had loki didn't realize what he was
getting into right he basically
underestimated the power of the century
and ultimately loki did the only thing
he could do which was to summon the
nornstones and then use those to help
the avengers as best he possibly could
but then was killed by the sentry who
was essentially powered by the void
in that moment loki basically died now
the funny thing about this is that loki
had initially gone
to hella and had his name removed from
the book of health which is essentially
kind of this giant book that basically
has the names of those individuals who
travel to that realm when they die and
so because his name wasn't in there
essentially his soul could not be
collected and the idea was that he would
essentially
have himself reborn into a new form
which would come in the form of
kid loki the funny thing about this is
that doesn't happen right well kid loki
technically does appear but it's a
wholly different beast so again
lady loki is a pretty small moment in
the history of thor's mythos but it's
still an interesting concept nonetheless
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
i will catch you all later
peace